Today in this video we
are going to learn how
to make SQL even more
helpful and powerful.
So before the videos make sure
to launch and log in to Beekeeper
and then I've also provided
with you some examples that
you can download to follow
along with me if you would like.
So let's go, I encourage
you to do so, let's go ahead
and do this. So if I asked
you a question of write
a query to return the
average age of all guests,
how would you go about doing
that? So right now, if we
take a look at our, I'm gonna
open up Beekeeper here quick.
Here if I'm on Beekeeper, I'm gonna
come over to a new query. And if
I wanna find the average age of all
guests, and I go about doing that,
I would first off say, I know that
I'm gonna be coming from the guest
table, so I might say select star,
from, and then I'm gonna say guest.
So I'm gonna go ahead and run this.
And when I do this, I see that
I get all of the records and
all of the rows from my guest
table. Now this is helpful
so I can see what does my age
field exactly look like. So I
can see I have just the integer
values of individuals ages.
So if I wanted to find the age,
let's see, if I said select
age from guest, now what's that
going to do? Okay, so now it's
going to just show me the age
of all of my guests. Now I
can't say their first and last
names, right, because that's not
contained in my select statement.
I'm just looking at ages.
So now what if I want to see the
average age of all guests? So
what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to use an aggregate function.
There are five aggregate
functions that are built into SQL.
Average, max, min,
sum, and count.
We are going to use average. So
we're going to say select average
age, A-B-G age, and then we are
going to give it an alias, as average
age. Okay, so now when I run this,
I am performing this function
on age. So it is going to find
the average of all of these ages
of my guess, and then name that
field average age for the output.
So I'm going to go ahead and run this.
Oh, there we go. All right.
So we can see here that the
average age is 28, okay? So that is
the average age of all of my
guests. So I am aggregating all that
data together and figuring out
what is that average age. So that
is how I would write a query to
return the average age of all
guests. So like I said, here we
have five built-in SQL aggregate
functions. So count counts the
number of rows for a given field.
Min returns a minimum
field, maximum field.
of course sum. Sum returns the
calculated sum for an entire field. So
if I wanted to add everybody's ages
together, I would sum age. Okay.
And then average returns again the
calculated average for a field.
Now, if we take a look at this, we come
back over here to our query number one.
And it says here, oh, on question
number one, before we go much further,
we want to have a little review
question here. I'll put the first
name, last name, and age for all
customers with the last name.
Gitson, Mason, Watson, or Wilson. Do
not use or. All right, let's go ahead
and do this quick, and then we'll
jump back into aggregate functions.
A little review session here to
get us our minds thinking about
SQL. So we're going to go ahead and
run that select star from guest.
I want to see, can you do
this on your own? Okay,
we are running this. Can
we do it on your own?
So I'll put the first
name, last name, and
age, so I'm going to
go ahead here and grab
first name,
last name, and age, okay, and now
this is going to return all of my
guests first name, last name, and
age. I am not limiting my records
being returned to me in the where
clause yet. So right now I have here
all of the first names, their
last names, and their age. So now
what I'm going to do is I want to
only return it though for students or
for customers with the last name
Gibson, Mason, Watson, or Wilson.
So I'm going to come over here
and say, use my where clause,
where helps limit records. And
I'm going to say where last
name, um, and I don't use or.
Okay. So I'm not going to say
equal to Gibson or last name
equal to Mason. Instead, I'm going
to use my in keyword, which
is going to allow me to put a
list of values here. So last
name has to be in Gibson, Mason,
Watson,
or Wilson, and to not use or. All
right, I'm going to go ahead and
grab that query, run it. And now
we can see that when it returns to
me, all of the records returned
to me must have the last name of
Gibson, Mason, Watson, or Wilson
to be included in my output. Okay,
perfect. All right. So now that we
got that out of the way, now we can
kind of jump back into our aggregate
functions, right? Because right
here, I'm not using any aggregate
functions, right, in this query.
I'm just selecting the
fields as they are, no
aggregation. Now what
I want to do, though,
is if I was to ask you how many
guests are in our data set, okay,
how would I go about to do this?
Would I say select count guest
ID as total number of guests
from guest, or would I say select
some guest ID as total number of
guests? So when I ask you a question
like that, let's go ahead and
do it. Let's try it out. So I'm
trying to figure out the total
number of guests I have, okay? So
if I said select a star from
guest, I'm just going to run this.
So the total number of guests I
have. So if I was to come here
and I'm looking here at this guest
ID field. So something to keep
in mind is when I use a count
function, I am counting the non
-null values of a field, okay? So
if I am to select count guest ID,
all right,
with this guest ID, I know that
it's my primary key, right, of my
guest table. It can never be
null. So this is totally fine to
count the guest ID as it will
never be null. another but if I did
say count age and there was a
null value meaning it's just empty
there's no value for it then what
I would have to do is I'd have
to recognize that hey there could
be a time when if there's a null
value that my guess is not going
to be counted okay so just keep
that in mine. When it's null,
it will have a big kind of null.
I will talk more about nulls.
But again, if say my age was
null for a guest, then that
record would not be counted
if I did say select count age
rather than count guest ID.
So I can say select guest ID. I
know guest ID is never going to
be null, and I can say as number,
let's see, total num of guests.
Okay, so if I was to go ahead
and run this, I can see that
I have 13,140 guests according
to counting my guest ID in my
database table of guests. So
that's how many guests I have.
The other way that I could
write this is instead of saying
select count guest ID is I
could actually say count star.
And what count star does is it just
counts the number of records. So
it's not necessarily counting any
specific value within a field like guest
ID is. It's just saying, hey, this
record exists. I'm going to count
it. So if I was to run this one
instead, I'm still going to get 13,140.
So this is counting each record,
right, each individual guest.
Now, back to my question of what
if we did select some guest ID.
What if we did that? So I'm going
to go ahead and do that. So I'm
going to say select, well, let's
just do it again, a select star.
Okay, so now I have my
select star from guest.
Now, if I, though, this
time, instead of counting
the guest ID, I would
say select some guest ID.
Now what this is going
to do as total num,
now what is this going to do? So
let's take a look at this. If I
sum the guest ID, what this is
going to do is it's going to say
guest ID 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus
4 plus 5 plus 6 plus 7. So it's
going to add the guest IDs together,
right? So if I was to run this,
do you think this is going to
be a higher or lower number than
what we receive by counting a
guest ID? I hope you said higher.
It's going to add all of those
guest IDs together, and when it
adds and it runs all those guest
IDs together, it's going to come
up with a much larger number than
13,140, okay? it's going to be
a much larger number. So much so
that it's going to be 86,336,370
would be my total number of guests
if I sum guest ID. So what do you
think about this? Is this the right
way to answer the question of how many
guests are in our data set? I hope
you said no, it's not. Because
what we need to do is we just need
to count the number of records. So we
only have 13,140 guests, not 86
million guests, right? So this may seem
easy at the beginning when we think
about the difference between count
and sum, but sometimes as we begin
to query a lot and we're looking
at, okay, am I counting this or am
I summing this? Think about it. Am I
counting the individual records or
am I summing values together? Okay.
All right. So the right way
to do this would be one of
these two ways of count guest
ID or count guests. Okay,
perfect.
So other questions that we can
answer with max, min, and average,
the other three aggregate
functions, right? Which guest has
the highest household income? Which
guest has the lowest household
income? What is the average
household income of all guests?
Just so that you're aware, SQL
will automatically round the
average value to match the data
type in the column that is being
averaged. Okay, so it's just
going to round that based upon
the data type of that column
that you're trying to average.
So let's come back here.
Those examples that I gave
you before, let's go ahead
and finish writing the
queries for those. So I'm
going to go ahead and do that.
All right, so let's take a look.
What was the highest average wind
speed recorder for a day in the
database, the lowest, and the average?
Let's see. Let's grab my Overland
ERD and Data Dictionary. So I'm
looking specifically for wind okay
so let's look at wind so if i take a
look here at the day table and i'm
looking for wind i want to figure out
what is the highest wind speed the
lowest and the average so i'm going
to come over here and i know that
i'm looking at my day table that's
tracking all of that information
about my wind selects are from day
all right so let's go ahead and do
this so if i take a look here i have
wind over here so let's look so i
have december 10th 2022 saturday
it's a weekday that's not a holiday
the skies were snowing the high
temperature was 33 and the wind was 12
and it keeps coming down here okay so
we see that so we have that's the
height so that's all of our wind
right for the different days in the
database. So what I want to do is
figure out what is the lowest and the
average and the highest wind speed.
So let's first stop by saying what
is the highest. So I'm going to
say select max wind and I'm going
to, if I just did select max wind,
let's run that, that's going to come
up with null. Okay and what that
means is I don't have, I didn't
declare it alias. So I didn't say as
highest wind okay so now when I run
this I can see the highest wind was
19 but now what I want to do is
figure out the minimum so what I do is
I just put a comma after that alias
and I work with my next aggregate
function and it's filled and it's
going to perform the aggregation upon
So I'm going to say
minimum wind as min wind,
okay? And then finally,
average wind, okay,
as average wind.
All right, perfect.
So now I highlight this. I go ahead
and press run, and now I have the
highest wind of 19, the minimum
wind of 2, and the average wind of
9, okay? so I can aggregate here
the same field in different ways
right so this is an aggregate function
right that I'm aggregating the
wind field for the maximum wind
value so the highest wind the lowest
wind and the average wind okay perfect
now the next question I want to
answer is how many employees work
for the ski resort so I know I'm
going to take a look at my employee
table here, so I'm going to look
at employee, and I tend to default
to counting the primary key. So
because I'm looking for how many
employees, I'm not going to sum the
primary key, right, because that's
just going to add those values
together. I just want to look at that
employee table to begin with, and
then I'm just going to sum, or then
I'm just going to count the record
ID. Okay, I'm going to count that
primary key. So let's go ahead and
do that. I'm going to just do
select star from employee initially.
And if it comes back with a connection
error, just run it again.
All right, perfect.
So I'm going to go ahead and how
many employees work for the ski
resort. So if I can see here, I
can kind of make sure I'm going
to get the right answer. If I
do select star from employee, I
come down here and I can see there
is 1,605 records, meaning there
are 1,605 employees. But the
way I can prove that in my query
output is I can say select count
a rec ID as num of employees.
Okay,
so now I'm going to go ahead, highlight
this, and press run selection,
and now I get 1,605 employees is
the number of employees I have
in my Overland Ski Resort. So
again, we have max, min, average,
sum, and count are my five
aggregate functions that are
really helpful in aggregating
or smushing, if you will,
all my data together into, in
this case, I'm looking at one
value here of 1,605 employees
that work for the ski resort. So
I can start to answer different
questions and do more operations,
if you will, with my data with
these aggregate functions.
right, so that's a good
introduction to aggregate
functions. keep moving on
throughout the videos to learn more
different SQL techniques
that can help us understand
and consume our data data
more efficiently. Take care.